got millions and millions more votes i'd
be the greatest
women's basketball coach in history
because i don't like lebron james i said
to president xi of china do you have a
drug problem no no no a friend of mine
recently said that i was the most
persecuted person in the history of our
country
you got it darling i'm so proud of my
girl
i ran for president
i won and i won a second time did much
better the second time
hi joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly
swear
[Music]
under the democrat rule
in democrat-run cities
democrat-run states and a democrat-run
federal government
the criminals have been given free reign
more than ever
before country is now a cesspool of
crime murder in our country is up 51
we are a nation in decline
we are a failing nation
we are a nation that has the highest
inflation in 49 years
and where the stock market just finished
the worst first half of the year since
1872
[Music]
we may just have to do it again we have
to straighten out
you